Hi guys. Um I'm Jerry. This is Wyatt. Uh
welcome to our talk. We're talking about
the current state of browser agents.
Wyatt and I are founders of illuminate.
Uh we build realistic environments to
help train computer and browser use AI,
but that's not as important for today's
talk. Today we are going to talk about
three topics which is first uh we're
we're going to discuss what are browser
agents. Second, we're going to talk
about how good they are currently. And
these finders are going to be powered by
a benchmark that we actually just
published last week. And lastly, we're
going to talk about what it means for
you, the listener and AI engineer trying
to build with browser agents
today. So, first, very simply, what is a
browser agent? Um, well, our definition
of a browser agent is quite simple. It
is basically any AI that can control a
web browser and execute tasks on behalf
of the user. On the left side, you'll
see a quick gift of a browser agent
purchasing a power tool by essentially
going to a manufacturer and actually
ordering it and going through the
checkup process by itself. It's really
cool tech and it's only really become
feasible in the last year with the
advancing large language models and
infrastructure around
it. Now, um, explaining a little bit
about what's going on underneath the
hood. Most browser agents, not all, but
most browser agents are powered by the
same loop that you see here of three key
steps. Uh, the first is observing, also
known as the observation space. Browser
agents essentially take a look at the
given context of the browser they're
currently operating in and figure out
what to do next, right? They do this by
either taking a screenshot, this is the
VLM approach, or there are some browser
agents that also extract uh the HTML and
the DOM. This is more of like a text
based approach. After figuring out the
context, the next thing that they do is
that they reason through and figure out
what the next steps are required to
execute the task from the user. For
example, if I ask a browser agent to
purchase the power tool, maybe it says,
"Okay, I need to go and click the search
bar." Which takes us to the last step
which is browser browser agents can take
an action. Right? This is also called
the action space where browser agents
can either click scroll maybe fill in
some text um which then takes us back to
the first step of the loop which is a
new state of the browser and then they
need to figure out what to do next.
Right? So this is called the browser
agent loop. Um and this helps you build
some intuition on what's going on
underneath all of that action.
And there are a few major use cases uh
that browser agents have started to
penetrate in the last few months. Um
these are the most common ones. I won't
go into too much detail here, but like
just the voiceover uh the ones that
we've seen most commonly. Web scraping
involves essentially launching a fleet
of browser agents to extract
information. For example, a lot of sales
teams use this to find data about
prospects. Um software QA is using
browser browser agents to essentially
click around and test software that's
about to be released. Form filling or a
variation of this which is job
application filling is really really
popular today. A lot of automated job
prospecting tools are powered by browser
agents today. And generative RPA is like
a really catch-all broad category. This
means a lot of things but a lot of
companies are exploring using browser
agents that essentially automate
traditional RPA workflows that break
very often and you see this with
companies like
UiPath. Um so yeah that's kind of what
browser agents are. I'm now going to
pass it off to White to tell us a little
bit about how good they are. Yeah,
thanks Jerry. Now that we have some
context on browser agents, we can move
on to the next question which is how
good are they? So to answer that we need
to think about what it means to evaluate
a browser agent. At a very high level it
is simple. It is you give a task to the
agent. Did it do the task? Uh in
practice this is a lot more complicated.
So the first thing is how do you come up
with tasks for your agent to do? How do
you come up with that data set? We need
tasks to be realistic. Um they have to
be feasible. Typically there are some
there's a domain specific element to
them. Um and they need to be scalable.
You have to create a lot of tasks. We
also need to perform the evaluation.
Evaluations can be done uh automated uh
if you have like a val uh validation
function. They can be done manually with
human annotators. There's LLM as a judge
approaches. Uh there's a lot that goes
into that. And then finally, where is
the actual browser agent running on what
infrastructure? Um as you'll see later,
infrastructure is actually key part of
how well browser agents perform. Uh so
big thing to consider when
evaluating. Broadly speaking, there are
two types of tasks, retasks and write
tasks. Retasks are typically just
information gathering and collection.
Whereas write tasks involve actually
interacting with and like changing state
on a site. So read tasks are more of
like a web scraping whereas a right task
is really taking action what you would
want a web agent to be able to do. Um
write tasks are more complicated and
more challenging and both in in creating
them as well as actually for the agent
to perform them.
Now, this brings us to WebBench, which
is the benchmark data set and evaluation
that we performed uh last week. So, we
created over 5,000 tasks uh open sourced
about half of them. These are both read
and write tasks uh on close to 500
different websites in a bunch of
different categories. You can see in the
chart there. Uh as far as we know, this
is the largest scale data set for web
use that we've seen. Um so, we're really
excited to put this out there for the
community.
Um, now let's just take a look here at
the performance of a few industryleading
web agents on just read tasks. And
you'll see right away this is actually
really good. So we have a uh a baseline
of open AI operator with human in the
loop supervision and that sits at about
80%. And our leading web agent is
actually hitting right around there 80%
uh with you know several getting close
to that. Um which is great news for
information retrieval and data
extraction. Agents are pretty good at
surfing the web and finding information
and getting it returning it back to you.
Uh as we'll talk later too the failures
here that kind of last 20 25% are
typically infrastructure and internet
related and not necessarily agent
related.
So here is an example of a read
task. So it's just extracting
information, but you'll notice it's not
necessarily a simple task. The UX UI is
pretty complicated. There's multiple
searching steps and filtering steps.
There's a Cloudflare popup. Uh and
there's a few different scrolling
interactions that the agent needs to
partake. Now let's talk a little bit
more about write tasks. uh overall
performance on write tasks is much much
worse. Drops about 50% or more. You can
see that uh operator baseline there only
dropped about 10%. So operator with a
human in the loop just a small dip in
performance whereas fully autonomous
agents across the board had a much much
bigger dip. Uh the question here is what
is causing this? Why are web agents so
much better at read tasks and why do
they struggle so much with write tasks?
There's a few reasons for this. Uh, one
of the main reasons is that write tasks
typically are a longer trajectory. So,
it just takes more steps to perform
write tasks than it does to perform read
tasks. And the more steps a task takes,
the more likely an agent is to make a
mistake at one of those steps and
overall fail on the task. Um, this isn't
the only reason though. Write tasks also
typically involve interacting with more
complicated or difficult parts of the
site and the user interface there is a
little bit more challenging for agents
whereas reading you're typically
searching maybe filtering maybe
scrolling read uh sorry write tasks
you're going to be doing a lot of data
input you'll be doing data extraction a
lot more complicated
forms just all around it's it's a more
difficult
interaction writing also involves
typically login or authentication. So, a
lot of websites you can go on without
logging in and you can find information,
but if you want to update or add
information or delete information,
you're going to have to log into an
account. Logging in is a very
challenging activity for web agents both
from the interactive uh side of things,
the user experience side for the agent,
as well as managing credentials for the
agent. So, having a username and
password and an email for the agent uh
and managing that is a challenge. And
then finally, antibbot protections are a
lot stricter. typically on sites that
have a lot of right tasks as well as
performing right tasks can even trigger
uh anti-bot things like you know you
might not hit a capture until you have
to input information and then you'll
have a capture before you can input that
information. So here is an example of a
write task submitting a recipe on all
recipes. Uh the trajectory you'll see is
much longer. It also involves not one
but two steps for logging
in. And the UI here is pretty
complicated. It's a dynamic UI. The
agent is actually adding new uh forms to
fill out. And ultimately, I believe this
task was a failure. Um the agent was not
able to successfully submit the
recipe. So overall, this is combined
read and write. um our best agent got
about you know twothirds of the tasks
successful whereas the average comes a
little bit over 50%. And again that open
AI operator with human in the loop
supervision sitting close to 80% 75 80%.
So I think there's kind of two ways to
look at this graph. One is
pessimistically wow these agents aren't
that good. Um but I actually think this
graph is more impressive than it is
negative. The fact that web agents today
are able to achieve results like this on
a pretty challenging comprehensive
benchmark shows how well they are
actually performing even though there
there's been only about you know a few
years of development on web agent. So I
think there is a long way to go and
obviously at some point you'd hope this
graph gets closer to 100%. Um but
overall these numbers are pretty
impressive.
Now let's talk a little bit more about
some of the failure patterns that we
saw. So here are a couple examples of
situations where the agent was
responsible for the
failure. On the left side you can see
there's an example of a popup that the
agent isn't able to interact with. It's
not able to close and so the agent isn't
able to complete its task because that
popup is blocking it from interacting
with the site in the way it needs to.
Now on the right side you can see
there's just a timeout issue. The agent
took too long uh and ultimately failed
because it timed out. So we call these
agent failures because a more
intelligent, more capable uh agent
should be able to do these tasks.
There's nothing blocking the agent from
performing these tasks other than the
agents own abilities. This is contrasted
with what we call infrastructure
failures. So infrastructure failures are
more
uh related to the framework or
infrastructure that the agent is running
on rather than the agent itself. So this
isn't an issue of the agent not being
intelligent enough or not having the
capabilities. Um rather it's it's
something underneath that where the
agent is actually prevented from doing
what it needs to do because of the
infrastructure it's running on or the
framework that it's implemented in. You
can see on the left side the agent
searches for the site. It's blocked like
it's flagged as a bot and it's blocked
from even entering the site. On the
right side the agent is logging in. It
is site requires uh email verification.
The agent in this framework has no
ability to access that. So the agent is
unable to log in.
Looking at the performance of our agents
that we benchmarked overall. You can see
here we have
success agent and infra failure and then
agent failure. So again agent failures
are it's the primarily the fault of the
agent. It was it should have been able
to perform the task but it wasn't. Agent
and infra we couple together. There's
some times where those things are
intertwined. It's a little bit hard to
tell if it was purely an infra failure
or not, but broadly speaking, that agent
and infra is something along the lines
of capture, proxy, uh, login off,
something like that. Uh, and you can see
that kind of agent and infra chunk. If
we can improve infra, that's a huge
bump, uh, to the overall performance of
our agents.
Finally, the probably biggest across the
board flaw with agents right now is they
are very very slow. So you can see here
um this is the average task execution
length. Now it's a little bit skewed
because when agents fail, they typically
go down a like death spiral where
they're not able to recognize that they
can't do the task. So they just keep
trying and trying and trying until they
hit a timeout. Uh but even with that
said, we see that agents just take
forever to do things. Uh this is
typically because of the agent loop.
They have to observe. They have to plan
and reason, break the task down. They
make mistakes or they fail in their tool
calls. They'll have to retry actions and
it just takes them a long time to
actually interact with the site to click
around to navigate the site. Uh I think
the takeaway here is that if you're
going to have an async set and forget
application, you might be okay with with
some of this latency. Um however, for
anything that's real time, this is a
huge problem. And the latency issue
really needs to be figured out for any
applications to be effective in real
time.
Awesome. So um those are the findings
that we've discovered while benchmarking
agents on a wide variety of tasks. Now
taking a step back, we want to discuss
like what do these results really mean
for you the AI engineer trying to build
with a browser agent, right? And I think
there are three like big takeaways that
we would like to really uh impart on you
which is first um as Watt really alluded
to picking your use case is extremely
important right and I think the real
question you need to ask yourself is are
you building a read or a write use case
um as we saw from the results read use
cases today are already pretty
performant out of the box right not
perfect but if you're creating like a
deep research tool or or some sort of
system that uses browser agents to
retrieve informations in mass out of the
box products um work pretty well here.
Now, on the other hand, if you're trying
to build a product that involves more
write functions such as filling in forms
or actually doing work um and like
changing the state of of some software,
uh just be aware that like out of the
box browser agents might not be as
accurate as you want them to be. And
it's not that they can't get there, it's
that you're going to have to test them
pretty rigorously before releasing them
in some sort of production capacity. And
this leads to just building a lot of
internal evals um for your agents,
right? And this is important whether
you're building read or write products,
but I think it's especially important if
you're trying to create uh agents that
take right based
actions. The second key takeaway uh to
really hammer home is browser
infrastructure matters a ton. Uh again,
this is the second time you've seen this
chart, and that's because you can see
very apparently that like the browser
infra you choose can have pretty strong
performance swings, right? And so this
just means like really test the browser
infrastructure that you're trying to
build on top of. Try multiple providers.
A great thing about these browser
infrastructure providers today is that
they're extremely interoperable. You can
switch them in and out to test which
ones do better. Um it is all really use
case dependent. like different browser
infrastructure systems might have better
captures for your use case or might have
proxies that are aren't blocked for
certain sites that you're trying to
access. A great tip is if you're
building on a specific set of sites and
you feel like you're getting proxy
blocked, just like shoot your browser
infrastructure provider a message and
they'll usually be able to unblock you
like with with some capacity on their
side. Um, so just really make sure you
try different providers before you go
all in on building some sort of
production use case.
And I think the last key takeaway here
really is uh try a hybrid approach. So
like the report really showed us that
although browser agents are good at a
lot of things, they're not good at
everything and there's still some room
to grow, right? And when we talked to a
lot of our customers, a lot of people
building browser agents at scale. One of
the big techniques that people utilize,
especially for production scale use
cases, is using a mix of browser agents
for tasks or workflows that are more
long tail, um, more dynamic or change
often and mixing that with more
deterministic workflows such as
playright that we know are reliable at
scale and that can be, you know, more
accurate for a large volume, right?
Right? And you can kind of think of this
as like laying train tracks for the
steps that need constant movement and
accuracy, but using the agent for the
more long tail diverse, you know, roads
and trails that require a little more um
nuance and
capability. I think like looking ahead,
we fully anticipate the industry to
improve a lot of these problems. Um I
think a few key areas where we're
excited to see development on are first
just better long context memory as you
saw from wide stats like some right
tasks take almost three times the amount
of steps as retasks right so having
longerterm context on how to execute
those tasks will be incredibly important
for accuracy second is I think um there
is still a massive opportunity to just
build more like browser infrastructure
primitives um we talked about this but
like login and o remains one the biggest
blockers to write based actions. Along
with that, payments is also a huge issue
that we haven't even really started
touching yet. And I think people who can
build these tools to enable browser
agents to take these like primitive
actions on the browser will unlock a a
huge amount of value. And the last thing
is that the models that power these
browser agents are just get better. And
something that actually we're working on
is essentially like training
environments and like sandboxes to help
essentially train models within a
browser computer use environment setting
to make them better at example tool
calling or write actions things like
that. Right? So if you want to talk
about that you know shoot us a B.
Oh yeah. Um that's really the crux of
this talk. Uh the last thing we want to
wrap up with are some really cool
examples of browser agent actions that
we saw while executing this benchmark
that we thought thought were cool and
also a little scary. The first is um we
asked a browser agent to do some actions
on GitHub. It got stuck and it ended up
actually talking with GitHub's virtual
assistant AI to unblock itself. And
those is a little bit of like AI agent
inception that we thought was really
comical to watch as it converse back and
forth.
Um, here is a really cool example where
we asked a browser agent to post a
comment on a Medium article and that
comment ended up being the top liked
post. Um, and this was like a really
funny nod to the touring test and like
really makes you question whether or not
we've actually passed this moment.
Um, this is a fun example of we asked
browser agents to book us some
reservations at restaurants and we kept
getting, you know, notifications on our
phone of restaurants being booked on our
behalf by our browser agent. Um, we went
back and canceled those reservations,
but it was just a funny like externality
of real world browser agent
testing. And finally, the last one that
we actually thought was probably one of
the scariest examples. um I think this
was browser use was blocked by
Cloudflare when trying to execute a task
and instead of uh just giving up it went
and actually searched for ways on Google
to bypass CloudFlare verification and
this was a little bit of a like whoa
these things are perhaps doing emergent
behavior that we couldn't predict um
without testing it in in some robust
capacity.
So yeah, uh that's our talk. Uh we hope
you enjoyed and really excited for the
space. Um lots of development happening
very rapidly and we wanted to give you
guys a current snapshot on what we think
the current capabilities are so you guys
can build better and we hope to do this
on a recurring basis um every few months
because everything is moving so fast.
Thanks for your time. Have a good day.